you know I think we're inclined to sort
of generalize from ourselves because we
know ourselves the best but then people
go out and do mysterious things anything
oh wait that's a bad person I don't know
where that bad person came from so I
think that um you know I think we have
good impulses and bad ones i mean i
think given all things being equal we'd
want to be generous and do good things
and make things better but I mean
ultimately we're selfish and greedy and
a lot and not always bright some people
are smart and some people aren't and I
think and some people want to know the
answers and some people just want the
simplest thing I mean some people are
lazy and some people are energetic I
don't think there's any single way that
human beings are this really a month
you